STATE OF SONY:
Once upon a time, Sony was one of the largest
electronics companies in the world.
They were synonymous with home entertainment,
high quality cameras, and hit movies.
But, the past 20 years haven’t been so kind
to Sony as it’s simply been loss after loss
after loss.
Take their TV business for example.
Up until 2006, Sony was the world’s number
1 TV manufacturer, a title that they had held
for decades.
But, since then, it’s been the Samsung show.
In fact, Samsung has now held this title for
17 years themselves.
Sony didn’t just lose their dominant position
either, they straight up got sidelined.
In fact, Sony currently stands at 5th place
within the TV market beaten by Samsung, Vizio,
LG, and TCL with only 6% market share.
Things were going so bad that Sony actually
decided to spin off their TV business after
10 years of losses.
But, it’s not just legacy businesses in
which Sony has been getting burned.
They’ve had quite a bit of trouble entering
new industries as well such as the computer
industry.
After failing to break into the PC industry
for years, Sony would end up selling off their
PC business.
A similar story can be seen with their smartphone
efforts as well.
They haven’t yet quit making smartphones
but for several years now, they haven’t
even been able to break 1% marketshare globally.
To be honest, the only Sony segment that’s
still super strong is selling playstations.
Everything else is at best stagnating or slowly
bleeding market share.
Seeing all this, I don’t think you’d be
surprised to hear that Sony was tens of billions
of dollars during the worst of it.
But, despite all this, Sony has somehow been
turning this entire situation around.
After several years of losses, Sony has been
positing consistent profits for 6 years now.
Their stock graph tells the same story.
After their peak in 2000, Sony would fall
over 90% over the next 12 years.
But, since then, they’ve recovered much
of these losses.
How could this be possible though?
Sony has been losing ground in basically every
segment that we know them for.
Well, join me as we take a look back at Sony’s
existential crisis and how they were able
to come out the otherside profitable.
STIFF COMPETITION:
Sony’s fall from grace shows how even major
corporations can falter if they don’t adapt
to changing times.
With high inflation and historically high
interest rates, we’re very much experiencing
a shift in the investing landscape.
Just last week, the Federal Reserve opted
to pause rates leaving us with historic high
interest rates of 5.25%.
Investing in bonds now means locking in high
rates before the Federal Reserve starts decreasing
them once again.
Companies and legendary investors are well
aware of this and that’s why they’ve been
investing hundreds of billions into bonds
over the past year.
If you’d like to leverage these high interest
rates for yourself, that’s where Silo, our
upcoming bond investing platform comes into
play.
With Silo, you can not only invest in treasuries,
but you can also invest in bonds issued by
corporations such as Apple, Nike, or Coca-Cola
all with no markups and $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance.
If that sounds worthwhile, please consider
checking out Silo in the description below.
But anyways, taking a look back, the story
of Sony’s fall from grace can be attributed
to a lot of factors but likely one of the
most consistent factors is repeatedly missing
the boat with new technology.
For example, let’s take a look back to October
23, 2001 right after the dotcom bubble burst.
Most tech companies were reeling from their
dotcom losses and struggling to secure funding
and improve employee morale.
But, there was one notable exception: Apple.
Apple had already gone through their own existential
crisis in the mid 90s and they were just now
starting to turn things around and October
23, 2001 was the fateful day that they would
announce the iPod.
In retrospect, this doesn't seem like a big
deal especially in comparison to the iPhone,
but this was actually a massive blow for Sony.
You see, eversince the Walkman launched in
1979, Sony became synonymous with portable
audio.
Just to give you sense of how successful the
Walkman was, Sony would go on to sell over
400 million units.
But, with a single presentation, Apple would
throw two decades of precedent out the window
and establish themselves as the modern music
player.
Fast forward 5 years to March 11, 2005, and
Sony would find themselves in a very similar
situation.
Samsung would announce the world’s largest
LCD TV coming in at 82 inches.
This TV was completely out of reach for the
average person but that didn’t matter.
This TV wasn’t designed to sell a bunch
of units or even push forward technology.
It was designed to make people think that
Samsung was pushing forward technology.
It established an association between Samsung
and innovation.
And this was just the first of many Samsung
theatrics.
Then you would have 3d TVs, curved TVs, OLED,
QLED, miniLED, nanoLED, and whatever else
they decide to slap before LED.
To be honest, most consumers have no clue
what any of these terms actually mean.
But, that doesn't matter.
All that matters is that people associate
all these new fancy terms with Samsung and
LG, not Sony.
And that’s not a coincidence, that’s by
design.
Basically the same thing played out within
the digital camera space as well.
Up until the 2000s, Kodak was an untouchable
behemoth.
They controlled over 80% of the US market
and about half of the global film market.
Not to mention, they were the 5th most valuable
brand in the world.
But, they would eventually drop the ball with
digital cameras making way for new competitors
to rise up.
This would’ve been the perfect time for
Sony to brand themselves as the leader of
digital cameras.
But, instead Canon would take on this image
and become the new dominant player.
None of this is to say that Sony was truly
behind in any of these markets whether it’s
mp3 players, TVs, or cameras.
In fact, they would usually launch similar
products in parallel with the market leaders.
And if you ask anyone who actually bought
Sony products, they would have nothing but
good things to say about Sony.
In fact, many experts would say that Sony
products are more reliable and higher quality
than these so called market leaders to this
day.
But, none of this matters because the reality
was that their competitors destroyed them
when it came to brand and market positioning.
And it wasn’t just one or two segments,
it was across the board.
But this only tells half the story as not
all of Sony’s decline can just be explained
away by just strong competition.
SONY DROPS THE BALL:
The reality is that much of Sony’s demise
is actually their own fault.
You see, Sony was very much bloated heading
into the 2000s.
They had just come off of an incredible run
throughout the 80s and 90s which led to them
expanding into every industry you can think
of.
Sony had a bank, an insurance division, they
were making anime, they were pushing out James
Bond movies, they were all over the place.
The reason that Sony was so successful in
the first place was because they were able
to produce extremely reliable and affordable
consumer electronics.
But as they expanded into every sector under
the sun, not only did they start to lose this
identity but they were spending more and more
time just managing all of these businesses
as opposed to running and improving them.
It was the classic pitfalls of a bloated company
with nearly 200,000 employees.
But, likely the best evidence that Sony had
lost their way was their executive team.
For some reason, whenever companies get really
big, they decide to hire random outsiders
as CEOs as opposed to someone who’s been
there and knows the company in and out.
Intel has done this, GE has done this, Nokia
has done this, and Sony would do this as well.
In the late 90s, Sony would hire a lifelong
media executive named Howard Stringer to be
the president of US operations.
I’ve got nothing personal against Howard,
but seriously, this guy didn’t have an engineering
background, had no experience running an electronics
company, and had little grasp of what made
Sony successful in the first place.
But for whatever reason, Sony would decide
to prompt Howard to CEO and Chairman of Sony
in 2005.
Also, let me note, he couldn’t even speak
Japanese which you would think is quite important
for a Japanese company with a majority of
employees being Japanese.
I mean, forget being able to talk with the
average employee.
How was Howard supposed to communicate with
his executive team who were almost all Japanese.
I’m sure they could communicate in English
but I think you can see why this isn’t exactly
an ideal setup.
Yeah, I don’t think you’d be surprised
to hear that Sony stock would fall 75% during
his tenure.
Likely the only notable thing that Howard
accomplished during his tenure was invest
in Spotify which to his credit made Sony nearly
a billion dollars.
But aside from this, Howard was more or less
just a dud.
But while, Howard definitely did make things
any better at Sony, it wasn’t all his fault
as Sony’s original secret sauce wouldn’t
have played out all that well in the first
place.
As we mentioned, Sony had built their entire
company and brand around the idea of making
great reliable products which is exactly what
people were looking for the 80s and 90s.
But, moving into the 2000s, consumer demand
very much shifted from wanting great products
to wanting great experiences.
This seems like a novel difference but it’s
not.
People became less concerned about the spec
sheet and the price.
They were more concerned about how the product
made them feel and how it fit into their lives.
This is exactly what Apple capitalized on
to great success.
So, even if Sony did stick to their roots
and didn’t get distracted by other businesses
and an American CEO, it probably wouldn’t
have played out all that well anyway.
This is basically what they tried doing with
the smartphone industry and it clearly didn’t
work.
But truth be told, it’s not all Sony’s
fault.
MARKET HEADWINDS:
Sony was very much subject to the headwinds
of tech obsolescence.
Much of what Sony was and is known for, people
just don’t buy anymore.
Take cameras for example.
Back in the day, everyone used to have a home
camera.
But, with the rise of smartphones, there’s
literally no reason for a dedicated camera
unless you’re extremely passionate about
photography and film or it’s your job.
The same thing can be said about mp3 players.
No one has a dedicated device to listen to
music nowadays, they just use their phones.
So, even if Sony stayed relevant after the
iPod came out, they would’ve just gotten
crushed by the iPhone anyway.
It’s a similar story with home entertainment
as well.
People no longer use BluRay players or CDs
at all.
They just use a streaming service and TV and
even that’s on the decline.
And speaking of TVs, theses are still extremely
popular but they’re also extremely unviable
as a business.
The TV industry has very much become a race
to the bottom.
In fact, TVs have been regularly dropping
15 to 20% in price every year for the past
20 years.
At this point, for Samsung and LG, TVs are
just way to maintain brand presence and dominance,
not a way to make profit.
This strategy works because they have plenty
of other industries to rely on.
The same, however, cannot be said about Sony.
The bottomline for them is that most of their
key industries have either become completely
obsolete or insanely commoditized both of
which are terrible for business.
This is why Sony was losing billions every
year and heading towards an ugly end for much
of the 2010s.
But, things didn’t eventually turn around,
so what happened?
Well, I wish I could say that Sony finally
figured out a new winning strategy and that
their making the comeback of the century but
that’s not really what happened.
All that happened was that Sony basically
got their act together.
In 2012, they put a Sony veteran in charge,
Kazuo Hirai and he basically just salvaged
the remaining parts of Sony.
He shut down their unprofitable sectors, he
reduced their workforce from 170,000 to just
over a 100,000, and he spun off their key
sectors into their own businesses.
So, essentially, he separated out the businesses
that were still salvageable, made them independent
of the bloated giant, and cut everything else.
This has allowed Sony to return to profitability
and recover much of their stock losses but
make no mistake, Sony is still just a shell
their former selves.
In fact, their biggest revenue driver after
the PS5 is not even an electronics division.
It’s actually their background financial
services division.
So, the glory days of Sony are very much behind
us which is quite a shame given how great
their products really are.
The silver lining, however, is that while
Sony isn’t making a massive electronics
comeback, they have figured out a way to achieve
profitability with what they still have.
And that’s a lot better than their Japanese
peers.
Speaking of Japanese peers, Panasonic also
isn’t doing all that great.
Check out this video to learn more.